here's a good idea let's burn uh the
woods in Canada so that we could breathe
it in New York and actually this came
from
Wisconsin wait you know like I know the
fires you live in New York yeah and I
knew I saw a lot of pictures of the air
and and but you are able to intake into
your lungs and irritate your lungs so
specifically with the knowledge no I
just knew that I I knew that I I've said
it to the doctor I mean I have a you
know underlying condition but I didn't
have this kind of a cough um and I was
in Wisconsin this was in May and I
literally two days later and and then
and then like the next day in Wisconsin
they boy I guess we shouldn't have gone
out yesterday cuz the air quality was
horrific well you jackasses tell me
yesterday now cuz all of us that were
you know Jeff the rest of us are all
like hacking and I've had this this C
since then you know what my wife would
tell you what yeah it's a dairy dairy
always
Dairy Wisconsin it's cheese that's
lactose that I know I love when they say
that it's really [__] okay and you
can sender that love for me you want to
call Mom you tell her you tell her tell
full [__] full of [__] I think she's
with my daughter but okay you can if if
you want to tell her she's full of [__]
with
my here what you don't believe in that
do you have any no why unless you've got
it unless she got a dairy problem but
she says we all do we all do we all
everything is because of dairy her her
um theory is hi we're here with lisis
black you're on the
podcast hello hi we're on we're it's
Howie we're on the podcast with ls black
hi hi hi he thinks that your whole Dairy
theory is [__]
yeah I have to he thinks my Dairy theory
is what [__] [__] you're
[__] oh no I I didn't say that you
were [__] did I well I'm saying
you're [__] wow that is that is
really
mean that was a mean thing to say why
would you call a guest [__] mean huh
it's Dairy she probably had Dairy today
why you say it's [__] how do you
know I I don't but I'm saying it's
[__] the proof is in the pudding is
which you're not supposed to have yeah I
know and then you're supposed to not eat
cake then because there's milk in it
right
yes you can't have it because there's
Dairy and pudding and what about what
about
cake what about cake what about
cake don't eat cake why are you say
what's wrong I'm not saying everybody
can't eat dairy oh really you just said
it you just called lisis black [__]
the proof was everything he did did not
get rid of the rush on his head until he
I said stop eating dairy you're allergic
to it and then the rash went away well
you know that but her original theory
was this that we are the only living
animal that is consuming milk this head
this head you had a rash on this head
right this head kids in the room yeah
that's the head not anywhere else not
anywhere
else but what what you're saying we're
the only living uh organism or whatever
that will consume dairy or milk first of
all from another species after we are
weaned mom yes I'm not saying it's not
delicious and it doesn't make great
stuff but I can't have it did my
daughter get to where she was supposed
to go wait this is we're in the middle
of a [__] wait I just want to ask I'm
having anxiety because I don't hear her
and she's dancing her little heart she's
doing the Renegade thank you
back you got to Le to be a better
Hostess that's my wife that's what I've
been married I'm better mom than I am
host we're not even talking about you he
she called him [__] oh oh it's all
about me I thought you were talking
about me
that was good that was good but but
what's interesting is is she backed off
the all all daras she can't say that
there are people cuz my uh she's shibly
diplomatic she doesn't actually believe
that she thinks every she she's
diplomatic yeah dair's the devil to her
yeah she's diplomatic well she's got and
her problem she said was Dairy right
that's not what she it wasn't even her
problem I had a rash on my head she told
me that she took away my
cheek well that's and my tour manager is
yelling about it I was I have another
friend who's going it's well you know
it's scary who's your tour manager uh
Ben Brewer my can we call Ben and see if
he says it's [__] oh no he I'm not
going to discuss this I've already been
through it with him I'm not giving him
any time to talk about his [__]
theory of Dair he's dropped Dair uh but
he's your what he's your road manager
you you probably spend more time with
him than you do with my wife yes
absolutely but it's I've heard it I've
I've had the argument with him you know
and all he's say is what your wife said
it's that Lis black is
[__]